بنسبه تضخمنا ووصلت الى 84% في المئه
وعمله تتهاوا يبحث حزب العداله والتنميه
على اوراق الانتخابيه تضمن له البقاء في
السلطه فالانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه
على الابواب يونيو
2023 قد
ناتي فجاه ذات ليله وعلى حين غره جمله
اصطبق بها الرئيس التركي اردوغان اطلاقا
العمليات العسكريه في سوريا والعراق
بالامس القريب واليوم استخدمها لتهديدي
جاره اخرى اليونان وفي اشاره ايضا على ما
يبدو لتوقيت الهجوم التركيه على قبرص قبل
38 عاما الخامسه والنصف فجرا القوميه
وخطاباتها الورقه او السلاح الاقوى في
معركه اردوغان الانتخابيه اليوم خاصه اذا
وجهت ضد خصمين تاريخيين الاكراد
اليونانيين والتوقيت مثلي توترات حدوديه
وحشود عسكريه
اللاجئون الورقه المفضله يتبادلها كلنا من
الحزب الحاكم والاحزاب المعارضه 2002
بنائيا حذرون من سوريا ليبيا والعراق
وافغانستان وستذهب كل اصواتهم للحزب
الحاكم بحسب الشعب الجمهوريه اكبر احزاب
المعارضه الحزب ذاته تعهد بوضع خطه تضمن
وعوده لاجئين السوريين الى سوريا خلال
عامين عبر الحوار مع نظام الاسد حمار يبدو
ان اردوغان الصداقه المعارضه اليها بعد
لقاءات المتعدده جمعت مسؤوليه اجهزه
الاستخبارات في البلدين برعايه الروسيه
تمهيدا للقاء رئاسي مع الاسد ابو
عيدانتخابات 2020 لا عاد دائما في السياسه
وهذا كلام اردوغان 20% هي نسبه واصوات
اكراد تركيا يمكنها ترجيح فوز مرشح
التحالف الحاكم او تحالف احزاب المعارضه
كما فعلت في 2019 نصفها يذهب الى حزب
الشعوب الديمقراطيه الكرديه بينما كان
العداله والتنميه يحصل على نحو سبعه في
المئه من الاصوات الكرديه
يبدو الوضع اليوم مختلفا خسر الحزب الحاكم
دعم الاكراد المتديننين بسبب السياسات
القوميه التي ازدادت التطرفا ضد الاكراد